I think we could see a different outcome
I agree especially because regardless of
alireza being as Donya called him Ali
Ali ricken for Reza right I'll I'll
leave freaking farooja
um it despite that Magnus Carlsen still
has that edge right that that made him
the goat and got him to be the best
player in the world the highest rated
player in history that I think if he
gets on a roll there's a little bit of a
psychological Factor right where players
can struggle against him because he's
Magnus and so you've really called it
well I think if Magnus gets off to a
good start
maybe maybe this match goes the other
way right and he's the one winning by
three games so I either way at this
point no more speculation needed we have
chess on the board arugia with a little
bit of an edge here to start game one
yeah although the pawn structure is such
that it looks pretty bad for white and
I'm looking at the clock Magnus up 15
seconds so he was doing this in their
first match he was well ahead in the
clock but what Magnus just showed
against Dania he has the mouse feet at
the end of the game as well so right now
I'm liking magnus's position he may be
uh you know actually he's not even
Downing material anymore after he stole
the d-pawn oh whoa a queen sack because
if you take the Queen the beep Pond
would become a c pawn and then become a
new one
that was awesome
okay it's still a 50 50 game but as you
said Magnus way up on the clock uh oh
but now things have turned around and
for Rouge has got attacked Magnus is
like unbelievable there
wait no Magnus Magnus turned it around
there I'm sorry I was losing track of
who was who no you're you're fine that's
happens in bullet even for the players
like am I am I black in this position
yeah you are oh my goodness Bishop takes
H3 with mate on H2O
a brilliant move to start game one with
a little bit of a head Bob whatever
Tunes he's listening to it is working
for Magnus Carlson yeah that was the
best start you could possibly imagine
and now otherwise with the black pieces
look at this opening Advantage for
Magnus he gives I I think in bullet
chess having double isolated pawns is
the worst thing in the world
yeah well I mean even in regular games
double dice or not everyone's favorite
but bullet Jets especially they are they
are things that you wish you could just
like literally give away right because
you'd rather have the open lines the
open files and diagonals and bullet to
give you some tactics so I I agree um uh
Magnus much better in game two you
called it Perugia started out with a 3-0
lead earlier this week if Magnus
reverses that script
you could have Carlson Nakamura in a
final I mean he's just cruising right
now this Knight is going to land on D5
in the near future like right now our
rookie won first okay I don't know if it
matters so much but he brings his name
don't take the bishop because Knight F6
check the queen would still protect the
bishop on C6 Magus he drops the C2 Pawn
though and that gives Ali razor some new
life
yeah and he's got the bishop here now
one is off the board but still this is
much closer to equal arugia also playing
faster this game still down on the clock
but not nearly the deficit it was in
game one oh gosh although as I say that
uh oh as I say that it's going the other
way for Rouge is shaking his head
and again not not calling calling anyone
out in any way but I am calling the
momentum Mount Magnus has already won a
match today he's looking fresh feeling
fresh in his home environment Borussia
looks a little tired just gonna be
honest right he doesn't look as uh as
fresh as he did earlier in the week so
we'll see if he can shake off whatever
is uh whatever the fogs are or he's
facing a 3-0 deficit maybe he needs Fabi
to show up and tell him he's looking
fresh because some people are the
recipient of that com and others they
never get it but for farouza it doesn't
matter what we say it matters what he
does and here he is the white pieces and
Danny he's worse once again look at
Black's Army in the center
so good you nailed it on that by the way
so by the way Bobby is looking fresh and
I just want to say that again
um all right yeah the Pawns in the
center
pressure on the king you always say
bullet King safety even more relevant
right because you don't have the time to
work yourself out of a bind that's an
important trade there for Perugia to get
get some of the tactics out of the way
but look at this Magnus just rolling
still up on the clock again by four
seconds
this is this is a different Magnus
Carlson and we know Nakamura is watching
what are we gonna have here if Magnus
moves on to the final I mean you saw
what the arrows I just drew there's at
some point going to be an attack on the
diagonal going for Queen h2mate like
right now he goes Queen E5 85 right now
but he loud the queen
an inaccuracy for Magnus
for sure for sure that's a huge huge
moment and this might be a huge save
aruja needs to stop the bleeding you
don't want to fall down 3-0 Magnus
wasn't able to recover from that earlier
he needs to hold this game but Magnus is
slightly ahead in the clock so he should
use as a weapon and honestly I think
Magnus what he should do is avoid losing
that sounds like duh you never want to
lose but you do not want to give I'll
raise that confidence so he's locked the
position up and he's going for a win
oh my gosh look at the pawns look at the
king
Magnus Carlson wants the 3-0 start if
borugia gave him earlier this week
returning the favor
look at this amazing again he's still
cut the king off
yeah that was brilliant with the Rook
and I'm looking at the time but it's
coming down to time oh my gosh it is
blunder apparently but not much time for
either player
there is no time Magnus on a king run
wants to flag him but look at farrugia
flexing the better time scramble skills
and die of a match is in the chat what's
up Dona saying that Magnus forum is a
hundred times today what it was
yesterday but for ruja just showed off
the mouse speed and that's the annoying
thing when someone has a rook and you
just have a bishop Bishops can't deliver
checks when the king is on the opposite
color the Rooks can just pester you
across the board and the King was cut
off so limited movement for Max's pieces
and I'll raise up better with black in
this game
yeah I love it and it's a really
instructive point for bullet the idea
that The Rook is just an easier piece to
play with there than the bishop the
bishop was constantly worried about
blundering right moving to the wrong
Square The Rook The Rook was in a
dominant spot which allowed feruji to
pre-move his way back into a Time
Advantage so interesting stuff
um
all right
Magnus still has a game lead but
ferrugia seems to have found it a little
bit
yep I can read between the lines here
what you're seeing this game is not the
most interesting bullet game we've seen
today you can hear that in my voice it's
like my voice goes higher when I'm
insecure oh my brother oh
under the fork
look at look at the Bob the music
we obviously are gonna ask Magnus what
he's listening to No matter how he
finishes on the day
that was actually a potential match
changing blunder because yeah there is
up a pawn he was better and there was no
risk in the position except he fell into
a night fork and that happens in bullet
chess watch out for the knights
note that Magnus didn't walk into the
fork on E2 there with that nice King H2O
very smart flexing the Rooks dominance
over the night he's gonna take a 2-0
lead urugu doesn't waste any time
on the clock gets right back at it yeah
three to one in magnus's favor right now
two point spread as you mentioned and so
we see it's now Carol Khan time and
alireza he's a proponent of the caracon
and this is just a weird opening this
Knight on C6 came from G8 like how do
you explain that to somebody
oh I love that comment from Jr scribe
what would be spooky is if Magnus said
he wasn't listening to any music
anyway that would be that would be
awesome by the way the chat did say
Magnus Carlson is the favorite here 54
to 46 thanks for voting chat
um we'll see if you're right
I mean what's right is this position for
black like oh what a tactic that Knight
could be captured in two ways but the
Knight was pinned on the diagonal and
then when you capture the queen look at
all of Black's Army and white has a
limited one
and by the way look at E5 what a strong
move to flex the center knowing that you
can't take that ball without opening up
lines for The Rook especially in bullet
you don't want your king to come under
Fire so Magnus
Magnus as Don just said
his form is fire today
oh and look at this H4 move where's the
queen going F6 is next you couldn't play
F6 because the queen was in touch with
G6 now oh he gets the queen into F2
Queen
he didn't even see queen of two and he
loses the Knight and he's uh
he's feeling the pain right now
I I sorry alireza I didn't see that
either but Magnus did and that's all
that's important because Magnus is Curly
out to a three-point lead this is a
complete role reversal of their first
match
yeah
yeah we will ask Magnus to share his
playlist he'll he'll do that at some
point we'll see if he's willing
um all right yeah Magnus has completely
turned this around
in terms of how he played earlier this
week but Perugia still has time if he
can we know what he's capable of here he
goes
some tricks here for black
oh watch out for Queen H4 uh oh Queen H4
so black has two minor pieces for a rook
in a pawn but black has this Knight
entrenched on E3 and it's not going
anywhere unless you trade off and the
next Knight might be able to replace it
but Magnus fighting well but I'll raise
a quicker on the clock
yep but this is the kind of game frusia
needed here this is a turnaround he's up
on the clock he's better on the board
this is probably the best game we've
seen him play so far we'll see if he can
convert it
he better I mean don't fall for any
tactics uh this these moves for black
have all been good the knights Wheeling
into E3
and this is just great play for alireza
yeah up a piece
20 minutes on the clock everyone take a
breath I expect this one to be close
watch your breath breathe into your
diaphragm because that sends a message
from your brain that tells your body
it's okay to relax I've learned that
wait your brain your brain works oh I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding sorry it
had to I had to I'm sorry
that tells your brain to relax which I
need to do often for my brain
um to remind it to keep working I feel
bad now all right I I just I've got to
be honest I feel bad I'm I feel I feel
great about this I love the role
reverser here you're hosting you're
roasting you're doing it all I love it
did you just go full Walt Clyde Frazier
on me
hey
oh God still got a few a few drugs in
the back um all right well Rouge is up a
piece but Magnus likes saying that he's
got a three-game lead he's gonna get as
much time off the clock as he can
um you know again winning and up seconds
I don't expect this one to go any other
direction but but a farooza win
yep and hosting and roasting for the
boys
[Laughter]
Magnus looked a little bit bothered by
that defeat and you know he was able to
rebound immediately the last time around
uh but we'll see in this game as he goes
back to what seems to be his trusty
caracon
yeah he's playing the Carroll Khan but
farusha with a better position I think
if this one goes for rouge's way and he
wins two games in a row for the first
time today
uh I don't know that Magnus is going to
keep going back to the carrollcon just
prediction
this does look pretty awesome for black
I mean the white has these terrible
pawns bad Bishop on G2
all white it was looking better yeah
I've seen better Bishop pairs in my life
yeah yeah some of the moves come in chat
so fast that it you can't keep up right
because they are literally playing at
human speeds that are faster than the
broadcast technology literally like like
we can complain about it but the reality
is they're playing chess faster than
then we can sometimes keep up with
that's just the truth
um we should celebrate it for being
incredible we should celebrate it and
Borussia should celebrate this position
although I'll say this the eval bar
doesn't tell the story of how tricky
this is Magnus has two knights the white
king is open I see Hess nodding a lawn
that always feels good to this low
self-esteem International Master when he
agrees with me well thank you for that
um
and uh okay but I do agree right this is
trickier for farugia than the eval Bar
says this is a blunderable spot but I'm
looking at the clock and Magnus is
giving up yeah and the g file yeah H6 by
the way was an awesome move because if
the king took on H6 the queen would have
traded on D2 and that's why Max took the
pawn but he lost the game and now it's
back to a closer matcha here we go he
scored a couple wins there and what is
this from
we're getting like a
what it wasn't it wasn't a bomb Cloud
which I'm hoping for anyone who follows
me on Twitter we need a little little
Bond Cloud earlier today but uh oh
Bishop H5 that's an exchange did Magnus
just missed that
he did but you know what's funny about
that is he still has like a ton of
compensation because the bishop can't
move from f8 and now that you've castled
Queen side maybe white can try to drum
up some pressure over there
a nice move F5 forces on passant which
is you gotta Rook you got to open files
and that's what Perugia will need to
flex The Exchange advantage and look at
this he's I mean if if a third win in a
row happens and we are deadlocked at
four you know all your friends we keep
saying it it's Friday take off work it's
already afternoon where most of you are
so let's go
yeah
Magnus is doing his best he's trying to
play quickly and just pose a few
problems and he's going after the H7
Pawn if he can trade the king side off
that gives him better chances
yeah he wants to keep the Queens on the
board get something going with an attack
I like Queen E6 look at Perugia
that was amazing geometry
yeah
we always say retreating moves are the
hardest to spot especially with no time
Perugia
put on a clinic here of how to convert
an extra Exchange in bullet and by the
way
okay I was gonna say he's not too down
on the clock he is down four seconds
though
Arusha is the
is the Peru Ali freaking farrugia has
tied this match
yeah he said hand down man down that's
Checkmate in the corner and that was
sweet from fairuz that was an excellent
game he has won three in a row he hit
the turkey if you like bowling but look
at this position now Magnus as you said
when you've double isolated pawns get
rid of them because it opens up the
space for the rest of your pieces and
both players they're playing this very
quickly such a weird position
yeah this is one that it's hard like
every move looks like a blunder because
Rook C8 not win a piece I mean like I
don't know what's going on here like but
uh the players are are holding their own
especially with uh okay only 15 minutes
left and we are tied even with magnus's
fast start this one is going to come
down to the wire and let's remember fans
you have to win by two in the new BCC
format which I love and uh make sure
that it has us here to the very end I'm
looking at the clock alireza is up
several seconds he's also up a pawn this
is another game that's going on the
razor First's way and he needs to not
let up Knight C5 that one a piece I
think oh but that one's an exchange so
he wins the game Magnus is tilting
yeah he's frustrated he's about to lose
his fourth game in a row we saw him kind
of uh
take a beat and take a breath and then
take a swig of water right sometimes
that's the hardest thing to do in these
online formats Robert is just gather
yourself right because there's no
there's no time to shake off the
emotional effects of of a bad loss and
uh
and Magnus has got to get his head right
here Ali Reza farouza has won four games
in a row if you just joined and
sometimes when you lose a Time scramble
like Magnus did when he had to Bishop
and a bunch of pawns for a rook is you
start getting worried that in future
time scrambles you'll also be the slower
player so that was a huge win in that
game from not just on the scoreboard but
whoa Magnus is but giving up a piece for
two Central pawns here
I was about to say great then I was like
is it tilt Magnus sacrifices a piece
from a practical perspective you've got
to likewise chances
even if the engine is saying that black
is better
but look at that oh leaving the tension
pinning the Knight on B3 and so Magnus
passed pawns they gotta start rolling
but this Knight's not gonna slide into
E6 to stop the past d-pawn
it's the bluff the psac was a bluff the
bones are going nowhere
Magnus Carlson could be losing his fifth
game in a row
he needs Daniel yeah oh that was a huge
blunder he let the knights get traded
he's lost
yep it's over now and now he needs to
resign and get back at it he needs to
learn the lesson that uh that he gave
that he gave Dania in the last match
don't waste extra time
you can take on F4 take on E5 that's a
winning King opponent game and yeah he
needs to right the ship right now
because farugia has suddenly been able
to overtake Carlson on the scoreboard
it's a two point farrugia lead at the
moment six to four Magnus up four to one
yeah
six to four
Magnus Carlson has lost five games in a
row but you're seeing why Ali Reza
farusha is the only other person to win
a bullet Chess Championship title
besides the color Nakamura right this
guy this guy even starting slow
something woke him up whatever it was
and uh
he's a monster
he is and he's just playing principal
chess right now but the thing I like
about magnus's very bizarre opening is
that he's up on time so sometimes it's
okay to play Bad moves in bullet as long
as you play those bad moves quickly
yeah the balance of uh don't don't play
so bad that you lose but uh but make
sure you have an edge on the clock when
it matters is I like to say the key to
winning chess games is to play the best
moves fast
there's a night on D7 you almost never
see that
Rook d8 though what what is the deal I
see two but now you lose a piece
oh Knight F6 check is a big threat how
do you stop that Magnus is and you see
him dejected there he reacts Knight F6
check is going to be mate with the Rooks
on the D file and borugia is going to
win his sixth game in a row bullet it's
a it's a game of momentum more than
anything else and farrugia is on fire
right now this has been exceptional to
witness and farrugia it looked like he
was shaky at the start and he's saying
no I'm just getting warmed up Magnus had
that warm-up against Dunya and now here
in this match it feels like alireza the
worst uh of his chest he got out early
that's really good news he needs to keep
this up though because if Magnus gets
one win you know he smells blood he's
able to win several in a row
yeah Greg shihadi said it it's been a
brutal 10 minutes for Magnus Carlson but
there is still 10 minutes left in the
match so if you can pull it together he
has time
this this is still though looking like a
lot of pressure from Perugia whoa did he
sack oh it was made on G3 that was
glorious that was glorious it was yeah
that's such an easy thing to overlook
and well Magnus has a better Pawn
structure he's playing against these
doubled C pawns but for now all the
reason has more activity until G4
what's going on here D4 might be a move
you don't want to play especially
because he was up on the clock by a
second there was no reason to rush
Magnus getting maybe a little bit
frustrated here
whoa he's gonna trade look at the light
Square dominance what an interesting
spot to be in down a pond but
potentially better in the end game and
it's a big problem while you've double
pawned if these one Pawn was in the B
file you'd be able to create a password
look at that move C4 if you take now
your Pawn structure is permanently awful
and now white should just go oh why is
he alive with the king in
but he was threatened he was threading
Bishop G5 but Borussia should have taken
that chance
this is actually
a very dangerous game for Magnus because
with time going off the clock you could
lose
you're going to lose a lot of time in
the overall match here Arusha should
play on don't take the draw oh that was
a practical mistake for sure by farugia
but Magnus was up two and a half seconds
so that's why faruja felt compelled to
take that draw so I'm with you that was
a winning end game and he probably felt
that it should be but he looked at his
claw and that's what Magnus did better
he didn't play his best game far from it
and you said this at the beginning of
the show when we looked at donya's
accuracy versus magnus's it's not always
important to play the most accurate
moves because if you're doing it slowly
you're probably gonna get a flag down
the stretch and what is Magnus doing
didn't he just drop the B5 pod
yeah he did and he yelled at himself he
said oh come on man yeah you can see he
said it and uh at least he drew the last
game so he has stopped the bleeding
quote unquote but that was a horrible
blunder
arugia has uh has pushed him perhaps on
tilt here
's a tough opponent for anybody and he's
unbeaten the last seven games is there a
mate no that evil bar was Sky High and
now it's going back down and black
suddenly is playing on the queen side
yeah farouza probably missed some sort
of version of a win there that a pawn is
dangerous
might be might be losing it though okay
what was it oh wait what is it this is
just no it's king D7 but where's the
beef where's the mate I just win the
material
he's up a piece right now
and Magnus is faster look at him he's up
six plus seconds at the moment oh and
the evaluation bar is going down because
you can't keep this E5 pawn and now what
black should do is take the Jeep on if
you could take the Jeep on the chess.com
server says you make a draw so Bishop F3
Play Bishop F3 it is a draw he's trying
to win find it he's trying to win
yeah because of the match situation but
you can't win this game don't take the
Knight that loses
all right so he is okay now he's really
in trouble
Borussia put the pawn on a dark Square
though that was super smart
yeah sending the Bishop from doing
anything but it still should be a draw
well if alarisa can somehow out uh speed
Magnus then uh there could be a winning
chance but no Magnus is just going to
keep his King in front of the pawn and
we are likely to see any second now and
there's the draw 1.5 that was way closer
than I thought it would be
yeah but in a huge in a huge uh
practical win for Perugia because so
much time came off the clock there are
only six minutes and 50 seconds left and
Magnus is facing a three-game deficit
yeah he's up the pace has Magnus Carlsen
he knows that he needs a win and
probably win quickly he still has enough
time there's six minutes and 40 seconds
remaining in the match so he doesn't
have to go all in just yet but he needs
to get two games wins for him and not
lose anymore
yeah and farugia is just focused I mean
he is uh
he's not he's not giving an inch right
now
he's not and he's going for the good old
amazing what a smart move by magazine
also gets out of this pin so Bishop G4
will be met by Pawn to F3
yep
and he goes for it puts the Knight on e4
Magnus turning it around
again as you said there is time but you
have to start winning if you win this
game you've got time to win another
so don't blunder and don't panic
yeah that's really good life advice in
general so everybody out there no
blunder don't panic yes
it's really difficult to like keep your
composure and Magnus has been playing
fast but look at that all of a sudden
he's on the offensive
I would say if there was one difference
right now in the match and I I know it's
not over yet it's farrugia has just had
more pressure against against magnus's
King in most positions he's been the one
attacking the king and from a practical
point of view that has led to some
blunders although right as I say that
Magnus flipping the script on that
queens and knights coming after the King
on G8 oh look at this he wants Knight F6
and he gets it because it gets Knight F6
we put the pawn on D6 to interpose along
the sixth Rank and right now Magnus has
to stop worrying about his clock I'm
sorry he's about the position and worry
about the clock he needs to flag Ali
raise it here he is up a second but he's
burning clock
oh yeah and I wonder if he had D7 there
but yeah he does have time Knight H6 oh
just premium D6 the Pieces come off
you've got to remove the Knight it
doesn't matter just you can lose Pieces
Just Beat Faster than your opponent
did he did he blunder that night for a
second maybe he did no he did look at
that but that's the thing you that's the
right thing to do like Dania has done
this many times you just give away all
your pieces and just pre-move at that
point and he wins on the clock with four
seconds to spare and now it's just a two
point margin
yep yeah it's a really great employee
Robert because at a certain point you do
the math even a pre-move loses a point
second on the clock right that's the
fastest you can play on chess.com is a
0.1 second and so
you know at a certain point you do the
math and all you have to do is free move
to flag your opponent right yeah and and
also when you take a pawn you expect
your opponents pre-move the recapture so
your opponent the per like obviously
took the pawn on B4 he expects magnets
to recapture him before but Max doesn't
so he's not anticipating that he could
take this Knight on C3 next and that
sort of shocks you so I think that you
just pre-move in those situations and
now Magnus he won the last game look at
this position up a few seconds
dominating the queen side with control
of the C file and white is cramped that
Bishop on c2's a glorified Pawn
yeah and remember you have to win by two
so if Magnus wins one more game he's
already in that spot where if time ran
out he would still be the uh
having a Fighter's chance here yes and
he's got a great position right now even
material uh the bishop finally gets out
and it's traded and he wants a pass Pawn
Magnus keeping the lead on the clock
Danny this is a different Magnus than
earlier in the match he's changed his
strategy to just be faster than alireza
yeah playing faster and by the way he's
kind of playing better while playing
faster so right now if he wins this game
and we are back within one uh the uh
the route is not oh but look wow what a
nice trick that Knight is coming into F5
that Rook is running out of squares oh
my God he's holding the Rook with the
King
position King C4 traffic on D3 okay he
gets his squared F3 it's an ugly square
but here's again Magnus just has to move
it doesn't have to be perfect chess the
evaluation may go into other business
favor but just go
just go he takes the Knight wins a piece
for ruja going for tricks but we have a
one point match everybody
call Mom tell her to tune in
mom the meatloaf
I'm watching twitch on chess
oh my goodness it's a one point match
and look at this position both sides
with doubled C pawns and this is a weird
position but I could see an exchange
sack on D5 at the moment
yeah and I can see black not wanting to
take it and playing C6 but okay the
Rooks come off the board B6 is played
some double pawns only a mother could
love for both players doubled C pawns
this is one that almost feels like a a
take a breath game for both players
Robert like all right
match has been set the stage has been
set Magnus shows he's not going away
um and uh this one is probably gonna end
peacefully
probably but as I'm looking at the clock
yeah you're right like is Magnus trying
to lock up the position and then he
strikes that forward let's say at the
right moment strike and then F5 and then
things get a little bit complicated
H5 becomes weak You'll Play Knight G2
here probably hold on he does
but at some point F5 comes oh borugia
forces the issue but E5 and F5 who's
getting there that's a huge mistake
oh my gosh
up seven seconds and his pass bonds are
mobile whereas his Knight blocks the
enemy pass on this is just the pawns are
pushing up the board and I think white
is taking this game
it's funny the Panic there by farugia
was something we haven't really seen
today but I think he looked at the clock
didn't want Magnus to grind him Robert
whoa was that a mistake how do you break
through if you're Magnus knife
he goes for it six but eight but there's
H2 but Knight D7 and you get your queen
with mate
aha uh-huh oh my gosh it's gonna be a
tied match yeah
look at ferocious like all right
all right
here we go tide match less than a minute
to play we're going to overtime boys and
girls buckle up it's sudden death
dodgeball but the players better
remember that because it's easy to
forget it's win by two and so you may
get really frustrated you know may get
very emotional but this is not a Do or
Die moment it's not going to be good for
other players to lose but your
tournament run is not over if you do in
fact lose this game
yep
what it what a match of momentum this
has been Robert Magnus up 4-1 borugia
wins five six games in a row almost
right well and now Magnus turning it
around
what has happened he might be about to
win his what is that well this will be
his fourth game in a row if he wins this
yeah he was down by three and now it's
even so it would be the fourth win and
he's better with the black pieces look
at his uh fluidity and the pieces all
doing something but the bishop B3 that
scares you even if it doesn't actually
threaten anything
nice use of fluidity
all right here we go momentum in this
match is crazy
the uh it's funny right as I said that
farusha's been the one with most
attacking chances I feel like that
turned around and Magnus has been
putting a little more pressure on white
skin you said he's been playing faster
that's the consistent thing that's
changed now he's up again
Magnus Carlson has turned this thing
around and now he's bobbing his head to
music again aruja needs to find it and
oh the rook's Trap too so Bishop G4 is
coming
oh my gosh
all right
time is out but it's win by two does
farrugia know that he's looking at the
clock
yeah he does he's locked in he does
and this is it if Magnus wins this it's
over
oh my goodness it's overtime it's free
chess don't go anywhere this is exciting
stuff and for Magnus Carlson he has won
four games in a row but right now he's
sacrificed two pawns at the moment he's
playing a Gambit line
playing a Gambit line he's going for it
he wants the kill
Arusha in a good spot though the king is
out of the center no longer in danger
what is this Knight F6 and D5 so
okay but you said no longer in danger
the black king is worse than the white
king even though Black's up a pawn so I
like magnus's slight lead on the clock
and the fact that he's no longer down
material
yeah and farouza shaking his head but
again even if he draws this game he's
still in the match so farusha has got to
gather himself keep his Focus so this is
a rook end game essentially with Queens
this should be a draw objectively if the
best chess is played ferruja needs to
play fast and hold on wow what a spot
there by Magnus by the way because Queen
bhacking by Queen like now mags you play
for a win you're up 10 seconds you flag
your opponent
yeah borugia has got to find a way to
trick Magnus here because Magnus is
going to flag him to move on to the
Grand Final and gets knocking more this
is it you got it you got it you gotta
change change what's happening here this
is scary territory for other reason but
we need to keep a count on the 50 move
rule at some point Magnus might need to
play the move F5 even if it's bad just
to try to win on time because right now
Alvarez has Perfect Defense objectively
the opposition is equal
yep and Perugia doing exactly what you
would do in both classical and bullet to
hold this game a master class if he can
hold on yes 13 seconds to make
50 moves basically okay but now he's
going for F6 and if you're Magnus oh
that's great play from farrugia
wow the defense
the defense from farugia
Magnus loses his opportunity to flag him
and that might be something that comes
back to haunt him if arugia ultimately
turns it around yet earlier in this
competition the first day of action
Anish Gary lost a match to Jose Martinez
it went to overtime when he was up by
one and he couldn't secure match Victory
and then Jose was able to take over so
this game here if alireza can win it all
of a sudden we're back to a tied match
and I have to say the way that Magnus
just played in that last game it looked
really good it looked promising but then
you get a bit deflated that you didn't
convert
totally agree the psychological Edge has
suddenly shifted back to Perugia here
even though he's down a game I
completely agree if Perugia gets this
one and he does have an edge
we've seen this match swing wildly if
you're just tuning in where have you
been your mom has been calling saying oh
watch the chess match on Twitch it's
totally lit and now you're here and uh
and for Russia
why did the evaluation bar go so high
there that was surprising
I was just guessing but yeah the queen
had no squares that was nothing but
that's helpful this again the engine
really helps us because you think it's a
normal position and suddenly with one
bad move it's winning for a side and
what is happening here H6 fell but this
past Depot in an open C file who's
better
yeah I I kind of like magnus's chances
here although I will say this farugia
has sped up no longer the deficit on the
time right as I say that
right as I say that gotta play Fast
Magnus is in a position to flag and win
the match uh oh you know what this
reminds me of that candidates game
between Ding and akaru like complete
chaos one side attacking one side with a
pass pawn and right now this Pawn looks
very scary and if he gets his Rook to
the first rank he can win this game but
the evaluation's still Level and magnets
up a couple seconds
what and now he's threatening rookie one
I'm like I'm freaking out this could be
the match could be the moment goes but
the bishop was hanging so he had to go
here and now there's Rook A7
seconds to four seconds Here Comes F5 oh
but the Rook was coming to A1 yes you
gotta get checks this could be the match
and if you're Oliver if you can get the
Rook off the board and I would blunder
it I was oh
my gosh
that was the match oh my gosh I was
about to finish my sentence if he can
get the Rook it clears the way to a draw
and Ali Reza he is faster when they just
have a couple seconds on the clock and
that is why he's still alive
but I feel like Magnus panicked there
didn't he have time not to lose the Rook
or no Borussia had gotten the edge on
the clock my God
oh
my goodness what's first you're doing
why did you spend all that time there
I was gonna say farouzia fighting for
his life but yeah mismanaging the clock
here down by 10 whole seconds that's
like like a peace and bullet although
that Rook might be a trap piece if
you're not careful but look at this uh
gives up the exchange to win two pawns
and have a rook on the seventh rank
Magnus he sniffed us out from a while
back yeah that was sneaky that was
sneaky
the only thing I'll say is that Rooks
dude if Rooks get going though in bullet
that's the only thing I'll say
oh but look at this passers can you
check and play G6
you have to play G6 or just put the
bishop on D3 and get it out of the way
push him yeah he does it I like that
push him baby
yep but Borussia holding on
but the the lead on the clock from
Magnus I think that might even be the
worst part is not only are there two
past pawns supported by Bishop and then
the kicking whoa he resigned seconds
early and Perugia leans back and Magnus
is celebrating he knows he's Gonna Take
It
oh my God is that it that's it Magus
moves on to the Grand Final and he's
dancing into a matchup against akara
Nakamura